this is Brian Kenner a convicted I or a
member
once jailed for armed robbery he now
leads a party called
Syrah meaning liberation police say it's
the political wing of the new IRA he
won't admit that but he won't condemn
violence either not even the murder of a
young journalist shot dead earlier this
year
how could anyone even begin to attempt
to justify the murder of Lera McKee the
death of Larry McKee was a very tragic
event it genuinely came about because of
the heavy presence of M PS knife London
to Derry at seven o'clock in the evening
in the price of the Craigan and it was
shocking and tragic and we were on
record as saying that we regret that
that very very much
but Lera Mackey's family and partner
don't need an apology they need justice
do you know the person who pulled the
trigger
no I have no idea of given so that means
but she didn't die as a result of a PSNI
gun it was a dissident republican gun so
is it not time for those guns to be
silenced well in in every generation you
know young Irish people have taken up
arms against the forest occupation of
our land and that is gonna continue
regardless so you believe an armed
campaign is justified well I believe
that it's inevitable it will always
happen so long as the country is
artificially divided and held by force
of arms people will always strike out
against an occupation booby-trap bombs
designed to kill police officers the
shooting dead of the journalist Lera
McKee as she reported from a riot an
explosion in a car outside Londonderry
courthouse attacks claimed by the new
IRA in his interview with Sky News mr.
Kenneth strenuously denied any link
between the terror group and his
political party the Police Service of
Northern Ireland rejects that there are
people who are members of Syria are
members of the new ra and some of them
are in leadership positions in the new
IRA so there is that inextricable link
between the the new your Ghanaians we
have seen an increase in their activity
this year last year there was one quite
tienes attempt to kill police officers
and this year we have seen sex incidents
four of which were very determined
attempts to kill police officers members
of the the PSNI but violence isn't
inevitable
nor is it excusable in dairies Craig in
a state the Republican stronghold where
the journalist was murdered there's a
battle raging for the hearts and minds
of young people while politicians
squabble over Stormont and brexit there
are dangerous groups attempting to
radicalize another generation here if
young people in the in the six counties
haven't been more politicized and in
some sense radicalized by the events of
recent times then what's wrong with that
if they realize that a their country is
held by force
and there was the time to resist that
but an overwhelming majority of people
on this island north and south voted for
peace
so what mandate is there for a
continuation of any armed conflict well
there was no man they didn't in 1916 and
people people decided to wear to take on
the British occupation with country and
so long the state refused to withdraw
they will be resisted by Irish people
it's 25 years this week since the IRA
ceasefire but police still patrol these
streets under the threat of attack
there's a political vacuum and dissident
republicans Noyce seek to exploit it for
some the troubles will never be over
David Levin's Sky News in Belfast